des couleurs et des signes associés
encore faut-il savoir lequel correspond
auquel les cinq enfants présents au
cours entendent bien et ont accès à la
parole il découvre ce nouveau langage
pour eux et semblent séduits
ça change de ce communiqué en parlant
c'est après ça a des inconvénients mais
j'aime aussi parlé avec des mouvements
on va dire ça intéressant de faire la
langue afin de savoir comment parler les
personnes sourdes les malentendants dans
des collèges tout ça maintenant il ya
les enfants sourds
et si personne connaît la langue des
signes pourra pas parler aux enfants et
seront pas d'amis un apprentissage
ludique comme ici avec une partie de qui
est-ce
les enfants ils apprennent vite ils sont
plus à l'aise donc déjà par rapport aux
adultes ce que les adultes sont plus
timides les enfants ils ont plus la
facilité de en demie mais aussi les
signes
une expérience concluante pour les
membres de cette association ils
oeuvrent pour la promotion et
l'apprentissage de la langue des signes
et il constate de réels progrès ces
dernières années on voit que un bonjour
langue des signes
on voit que maintenant c'est connu que
les gens sont au courant de
l'accessibilité et que cette langue
existe qu'avant c'était vraiment
choquant pour les personnes il n'était
pas au courant ça évolue donc c'est plus
sympa aussi pour est accueilli comme ça
une évolution à laquelle participent
timéo et ses quatre camarades en passant
trois jours de leurs vacances ici